[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que le monde
je m'appelle bertrand jusque là et je
suis membre de l'om aime l'organisation
météorologique mondiale et j'ai dirigé
un groupe d'études sur le climat en
partenariat avec le giec et le soutien
de plus de 14 pays européens
nous avons en effet reçu une enveloppe
globale de 8 7 millions d'euros ce qui
est une grosse somme
et après cinq ans d'études nous avons
compilé tous nos résultats dans un
article direct mais qui je crois
représente bien la situation climatique
actuel ses conclusions nous voulions les
partager avec vous ce soir
les voici
cet article de trois lettres et de trois
mots a été publiée dans la revue nature
de septembre 2018 traduit en anglais par
des pièces et en russe par dabou ch din
ya d'abord eu alors la langue russe
n'ayant pas le même champ lexical
fécales pour parler des situations
préoccupantes d'abrod pourrait se
traduire par parties génitales après un
accident de moto
fort de cette information nous avons
organisé des tables rondes avec notre
partenaire immo 2050
pour répondre à cette question cruciale
mais où investir dans la pierre après 2
degrés d'augmentation
il semblerait que la ville de plougastel
daoulas dans le finistère est amené à
devenir le prochain saint-tropez qui
l'eût cru
l'autre question non moins intéressante
est celle de savoir comment survivre
après une montée des eaux et à ce titre
il serait peut-être judicieux que vous
conserviez vos notes sur la conférence
sur la paix que nous venons de voir ça
peut aider
alors le thème de tedx cette année
c'était le kill tsugi cet art ancestral
japonais qui consiste donc à recoller
les morceaux de porcelaine avec de la
laque saupoudrés d'or c'est un art noble
intéressant mais bon ça reste un puzzle
3d en plus cher et ouais ça peut
toujours aider pour réparer la base de
mamie mais bon pour boucher la toiture
de fukushima ils vont pas au pinceau à
la feuille d'or
or pour bien faire face à l'urgence
climatique du moment j'aimerais vous
rappeler le terme de ma conférence de ce
soir
qu'on soit tous raccord avec ça le monde
a changé
vite il y aura des conflits mondiaux et
certaines catégories de la population ne
vont pas survivre en effet après de
nombreuses expériences que nous avons
menées nous avons distingué trois
groupes sociaux qui n'ont pas les
aptitudes nécessaires pour se livrent à
des conditions extrêmes parmi ces
groupes il ya en tête les gens qui
travaillent dans le marketing digital
tout ce qui est boulette poynton myler
une vague et cela dégage
[Musique]
dans un deuxième temps il y aura les
gens qui pratiquent le golf et qui pense
que c'est vraiment un sport
ouais l'un sans l'autre vous pouvez
survivre mais ça reste un comportement à
risque et enfin les gens qui écoutent de
la cumbia
alors pour rappel la cumbia c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc voilà si jamais vous avez hocher la
tête ou taper du pied
vous pouvez vous épargner lente et
douloureuse explication dans les
prochaines années
dès ce soir en rentrant chez vous et en
vous tirant une balle dans la tête
face à l'urgence climatique j'ai voulu
développer des stratégies de survie en
cas d'apocalypse
et c'est tout naturellement que je me
suis tourné vers la non violence alors
pas par philosophie ou par morales mais
par plutôt ce que j'appelle de la
cohérence morphologique
je suis pas con
et pour info la seule fois où j'ai dû me
battre dans ma vie c'était contre une
femme enceinte et même là j'ai galéré
après y avait un contexte était vraiment
énervée elle voulait me tuer mais
rassurez vous je suis pas un monstre un
jeune est frappée au visage alors
comment résoudre des conflits de façon
zen dans des situations extrêmes et bien
c'est la question que j'ai posée à
monsieur patrick mc kenzie que vous
connaissez beaucoup plus j'imagine sous
le nom de master quan accueillons le
tout de suite
master quan bonsoir parce qu'on est la
traduction aille à une traduction
bonjour
ma soeur pwan vous avez été un membre
très actif d'associations de défense du
port d'armes pour les enfants aux
etats-unis qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
la non violence car j'ai appris que les
mots pouvaient blesser encore plus que
les arts par exemple si je vous dis qu
après vous avoir observé depuis la
coulisse
je peux affirmer que la sur utilisation
de vos sourcils dans vos moyens
d'expression masque mal une pomme d'adam
trop proéminente pour votre maigre coup
ça fait mal
n'est ce pas ça fait très malin mais il
y a encore plus fort que les insultes et
c'est le non verbal
j'aimerais en faire la démonstration sur
un des membres du public et pour prouver
que cela fonctionne sur tout le monde
j'aurais besoin de quelqu'un qui a fait
des études
même si étant à clermont ferrand je sais
que je m'adresse principalement ce soir
à des artisans et des agriculteurs y at
il un volontaire bravo messieurs venez
me rejoindre
tout en recevant ses applaudissements
spontanés des nourris du public
[Musique]
regardez alors je m'appelle mustapha a
alors je suis dans le marketing digital
encore mieux car vous évoluez dans un
domaine où les baux est encore
supérieure au niveau d'études et où le
sentiment de fierté du travail accompli
et facilement atteignables voir actu
diaw et viau et jeudi j'aimerais faire
avec venus l'exercice 10 de la pomme si
posséder une pomme et je vais par la
seule force de mon regard tentez de vous
l'apprendre
ayo cela vous convient-il ok super
prenez cette pomme et regardez moi dans
les yeux
calmez vous vous va bien se passer
alors franchement au rwanda de chiots
avant tout je voulais vous montrer qu'il
existe une alternative à la non violence
plutôt efficace qui est la violence mais
maintenant passion à la deuxième étape
non violente je sais pas parce que là
vous m'avez mis une claque sur vinci
prenait 7 places et vous et regardez moi
dans les yeux
si vous placez paraître démonstration
avoir un chien au hockey je voulais vous
montrer que la violence est si efficace
qu'elle peut fonctionner à plusieurs
reprises les d'où l'extrême importance
de maîtriser d'autres techniques comme
scène absolument non violente que je
vais à présent vous montrer s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît restez sur les on
a des goodies
on a un bug en aveugle je vous promets
sur mon honneur de sensei qu'aucun coup
ne vous sera portée vous avez des mugs
et du cou ok prenez cette pole placez
vous et regardez moi dans les yeux
cette pomme où je vous tapez
avec un péché la pomme merci beaucoup
master thuan ont fait démonstration
simon que pour avoir recours à la non
violence
rien de mieux que d'utiliser la menace
très bonne soirée à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]